how are you good how are you doing I'm
good thank you listen revenge is a huge
theme in this series and this woman is
on a mission to get it have you ever
gotten revenge on someone or wanted to
do so really badly not like this I mean
this character is sort of moving with a
tenacity towards it that I've never felt
um but she has every right to and you
kind of realize that as you go along
she's a character with a secret and
she's a bit of a force to be reckoned
with even though when you meet her she's
like the image of the feminine ideal you
know she looks like a fish out of water
in the wild west but she um
she turns out to be a lot more than you
realize that's right and this I heard
you say this is your first time in a
western what surprised you the most
about this genre any challenges that
maybe you didn't anticipate seems very
dusty and hot
um yes it was very dusty and very hot
but I think you can see that kind of
shimmering on the screen I think it all
sort of lends itself to the experience I
had always wanted to do a western I love
the backdrop of a western it's all built
on Power and loss and this kind of
brutality
and yeah this felt like a western that
was
carving out new space for itself within
the genre
um so I never mind the sort of elements
that you find yourself shooting in it's
part of it
yeah it helps you create it you're not
only starring in it but you're also
executive producing between the
physicality of the role the pressure of
being a lead and the responsibility of
an EP how exhausted or exhilarated and
fulfilled were you at the end of the day
but the latter it exhilarated and
fulfilled I mean this shows my baby you
know I really
I feel very close to it indeed and it
was sent to me as a pilot Hugo sent it
to me and I've been with him shoulder to
shoulder every step of the way since and
um
yeah I feel creatively it's really where
I want to be is helping you know birth
these things and build them and I love
creating stories I love the whole I'm
not just interested in the acting
anymore I love it yeah I think as soon
as I'm done with the show
um and it's the same for me on Films as
soon as I finish that kind of acting
side of it I then really enjoyed the
aftermath of it too and I'm able to see
it from a different point of view after
I'm done
nice there is a there's a line in the
movie where or they're in the show that
says uh the difference between what you
want and and what you need is what you
can put on a horse so I need to know
what is the one item you need that you
can put on a horse
I could stick both my kids on the horse
love that love that yeah what about your
husband could you get him on the horse
listen that horse is gonna have to like
do some squats to be able to take all of
them but
all four of us I feel sorry for the
horse no of course yeah of course it
would just have to be one of those
really enormous horses you know to get
all of us it would feel otherwise it
would feel yeah like a good Clydesdale
could get the whole family on it yeah
you could just drag him behind it'll be
fun okay that would be like Western's
western style like tie a rope around his
ankles and just drag him along yeah I
love that I love that all right thank
you for your time congratulations on
everything thank you so much take care